oui
non
partout
oui
oh
fronte et à des choix quelques fois
déchirant enfin le cumul des mandats
nuit à la qualité du travail
parlementaire je n'irais pas jusqu'à
dire comme guy carcassonne que le
parlement manque moins de pouvoirs que
deux parlementaires ayant le temps
nécessaire pour s'en saisir
mais il est certain que le temps est
pour nous toutes et pour tous je crois
qu'on a bien vu ces jours ci mais ces
dernières semaines est pour nous une
ressource rare et que plus nous
consacrons à des mandats locaux
- nous avons le temps de nous consacrer
à toute l'étendue de nos compétences de
parlementaires c'est vrai pour le
travail législatif c'est vrai aussi pour
les activités de contrôle du parlement
celle là même qui dans les années à
venir sont appelés à se développer nous
en parlons souvent comme c'est le cas
dans toutes les grandes démocraties
aujourd'hui de ce fait le cumul des
mandats aggrave le déséquilibre entre
les pouvoirs en affaiblissant encore un
peu plus le pouvoir législatif déjà fort
encadré sous la vème république et des
débats récents notamment sur les
retraites lors une nouvelle fois
tristement illustré
c'est pour répondre à tous ces
inconvénients que le cumul des mandats
était progressivement nous l'avons vue
encadré au cours des deux dernières
décennies à deux reprises je constate
que c'est la gauche qui a permis ces
avancées ce fut d'abord le cas de la loi
organique du 30 décembre 1985 qui est
introduit dans le code électoral les
premières limitations
car faut-il le rappeler nous étions
alors à une époque on a incité souvent
le cas de personnalités fortes
monsieur jean lecanu et monsieur
chandernagor chacun d'un côté qui je me
limiterai à ces deux messieurs de
monsieur le président nous étions une
époque où l'on pouvait être à la fois
maire président de conseil général
président nommé eux avaient quand même
la particularité de d'illustrer d'une
façon presque caricaturale ce phénomène
de cumul des mandats on peut être à la
fois maire président du conseil général
président du conseil régional sénateurs
parlementaires européens président
d'agglomération et président de
commission du sénat ce fut le cas de
l'un de ceux que je viens de citer aussi
la loi de 1985 at elle rendu
incompatible un mandat parlementaire
avec l'exercice de plus d'un des mandats
suivants représentants au parlement
européen conseiller régional ou
conseillers de l'assemblée de corse
pour être complet conseiller général
conseiller de paris maire d'une commune
de plus de 20000 habitants autre que
paris adjoint au maire d'une commune de
plus de 5000 habitants autre que paris
en 95 alors la loi du 19 janvier a
introduit des dispositions
complémentaires puis ensuite on s'en
souvient la loi organique d'avril 2000
votée à l'initiative du gouvernement de
lionel jospin a posé de nouvelles
limites même si en raison il faut bien
le constater de l'opposition du sénat le
texte va beaucoup moins loin que ses
ambitions initiales
quoi qu'il en soit mes chers collègues
l'histoire du cumul des mandats est dans
le faux recel de 100 reculent et ce
recul est en même temps une avancée pour
notre démocratie
c'est pour cela que nous vous proposons
aujourd'hui d'aller plus loin car nous
ne sommes pas encore au bout du chemin
aujourd'hui un parlementaire peut encore
au cumul et si nous regardons bien
jusqu'à trois fonctions exécutives
locales puisqu'il peut être en même
temps maire d'une commune de moins de
3500 habitants président de conseil
général ou de conseil régional et
président d'un établissement public de
coopération intercommunale vous allez me
me reprendre dans un instant cette
proposition de loi concrétise un
engagement fort des socialistes je crois
que vous l'avez tous ceux constatés et
remarques et donc nos collègues députés
ont déposé une proposition de loi
identique à l'assemblée nationale est
aujourd'hui en toute logique nous
débattons de cette proposition de loi
devant notre haute assemblée car notre
conviction est simple le non cumul doit
être organisée par une loi de la
république
les règles doivent être les mêmes pour
tous elles doivent donc s'appliquer
indistinctement à tous les
parlementaires
quel que soit bien sûr leur appartenance
politique et j'ai particulièrement
insisté sur ce point il me semble
qu'elles doivent être appliquées à tous
quel que soit le l'organisation
politique à laquelle on appartient je
crois que c'est la loi de la république
qui doit régler ce genre de questions et
pas d'autres pas d'autres démarches ou
près ce processus d'évolution
c'est bien pour celà pour insuffler le
renouveau à notre vie politique que nous
proposons ce texte
aujourd'hui alors que voulons-nous
concrètement même si vous en avez une
petite idée
nous proposons donc un texte simple et
je m'adresse immédiatement à mes
collègues qui ne manqueront pas de me
faire de nombreuses remarques ce que
nous voulions c'est un texte simple
limpide et dans cette limpidité réside
le semble-t-il le gage de son efficacité
nous proposons et c'est l'objet de
l'article 1er de la proposition de loi
d'interdire le cumul d'un mandat
parlementaire avec l'exercice de toute
fonction exécutive au sein d'une
collectivité territoriale ou d'un
établissement public de coopération
intercommunale nous avons bien dit de
toute fonction exécutive maire et
adjoint au maire président dix
présidents de conseil général conseil
régional président ou vice-président de
pci tous ses mandats toutes ses
fonctions entre également dans le champ
d'application de notre proposition de
loi et nous proposons dans un souci de
pragmatisme que la loi s'applique comme
le préconisait d'ailleurs la commune
balladur s'applique à compter de sa
promulgation à chaque parlementaire
nouvellement élu l'entrée en vigueur de
la loi devra ainsi avoir lieu dès les
prochains renouvellements des assemblées
parlementaires
le dispositif d'ensemble puisque je ne
doute pas que notre proposition de loi
soit votée entrera donc en vigueur à
l'issue du renouvellement intégral de
l'assemblée nationale en 2012 et des
renouvellement partiel du sénat
prochain rendez vous 2011 puis en 2014
dans notre esprit cette proposition de
loi est à la fois un aboutissement et un
commencement un aboutissement parce
qu'elle va très loin dans la limitation
du cumul
nous en sommes conscients et qu'elle
prolonge ainsi une évolution historique
tout en permettant de conserver un lien
fort avec le terrain puisque le cumul
avec le mandat local non exécutif
demeurent autorisées et un commencement
parce qu'il faudra aller plus loin
cette loi doit être prolongée par des
dispositions destinées à moderniser
notre vie publique je pense qu'il ne
faut pas isoler la question du cumul de
mandats d'autres questions liées à
l'exercice de nos fonctions de nos
mandats et de notre vie publique et je
pense donc bien sûr là aussi nous vaut
un autre serpent de mer le statut de
l'élu et notamment le statut de l'élu
local
je pense au renforcement de notre
parlement et à la rénovation de notre
bicamérisme car la rénovation de notre
bicamérisme est une nécessité absolue
je pense aussi et président et le
rapporteur ils seront sensibles à
l'amélioration de la qualité de nos
textes de loi je pense un vrai statut de
l'opposition parlementaire qui à mon
sens n'existe pas aujourd'hui pour que y
compris si au sénat les groupes
minoritaires puissent être respectés se
voir confier des responsabilités
bref être pris davantage en compte mes
chers collègues j'en termine trop
souvent notre assemblée a été un lieu de
blocage dans la modernisation de notre
vie publique
je crois qu'il nous faut éviter ce matin
de tomber à nouveau dans ce piège
et pour cela monsieur le rapporteur
permettez moi de vous dire monsieur le
rapporteur gélard
permettez moi de vous dire
que nous ne pouvons suivre votre
démarche qui préconise le renvoi de
notre texte en commission en s'abritant
derrière des arguments qui pour moi ne
sont pas de bons arguments sont toujours
les mêmes qui n'ont qu'un objectif
dans le fond c'est de retarder l'heure
des choix alors vous ne serez pas
surpris que je terminerais pour je
terminerai par une phrase de jean jaurès
qui voit là il faut enfin dire
l'essentiel est fait rappelle à ceux qui
avaient une vraie pensée une vraie
vision de la vie politique et du mandat
de parlementaire jean jaurès qui
estimait dans son discours pour la
dépêche de toulouse le 28 décembre 1903
qu'il ya un intérêt capital à ce que le
sénat soit en harmonie avec la
démocratie
je vous invite donc à suivre jean jaurès
merci à vous
je parle est un patrice gélard
rapporteur de la commission des lois
le président tu viens
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre nous sommes donc saisi
aujourd'hui d'une proposition de loi
organique interdisant le cumul des
mandats des parlementaires avec
l'exercice d'une fonction exécutive
locale
cette proposition est déposée par le
président du groupe socialiste monsieur
jean pierre bel
ainsi que la totalité des membres de son
groupe alors il est bien évident que le
texte qui nous est aujourd'hui proposée
présente un intérêt réel et il convient
de rappeler comme l'a fait d'ailleurs
jean pierre bel tout à l'heure que le
cumul des mandats a déjà joué un rôle
non négligeable en ce qui concerne nos
travaux parlementaires
que ce soit avec l'adoption de la loi du
30 décembre 1903 85 limitant le cumul
des mandats électoraux et des fonctions
électives aboutissant à la pause de deux
principes le principe numéro un qui
serait le suivant un mandat national et
un mandat local
le principe numéro 2 qui serait un homme
demandant cette première loi de 1985 a
été complétée par une seconde loi
le 25 février 1992 qui limitent cette
fois ci le cumul des indemnités en
fixant à une fois et demie le montant de
l'indemnité parlementaire le maximum de
ce qu'un élu qui cumule plusieurs
fonctions peut toucher enfin la dernière
loi en vigueur c'est la loi du 5 avril
2000 qui est à l'exception des
conseillers municipaux des communes de
plus de 2500 habitants interdit les
fonctions les le cumul des fonctions
exécutives locales et il y a là un
élément qui était de la volonté de
lutter contre ce qu'on appelle les
candidats locomotive qui menait les
listes mais qui en réalité ne faisait
rien d'autre part la suite alors cela
dit il ya eu à propos de la loi du 5
avril 2000 une divergence sur le régime
d'incompatibilité des élus locaux et
celui des parlementaires en raison des
désaccords qui portaient les députés
face aux sénateurs
il ya donc là un problème un peu
particulier qui n'avait pas été résolus
par cette loi et où le sénat avait
nécessairement eu gain de cause y
compris dans la décision du conseil
constitutionnel qui suivait enfin plus
récemment et jean pierre bel a souligné
nous avons eu le rapport balladur qui
une fois de plus a mis l'accent sur le
problème du cumul des mandats je
souligne tout de même qu'à propos du
rapport balladur
le comité qui l'animait ne comprenait
aucun sénateur et que donc le point de
vue du sénat n'a pas pu être pris en
compte
à cet égard et que s'il y avait quatre
députés ou anciens députés
il y avait 0 sénateurs oui oui j'admets
c'est vrai c'est vrai que c'est vrai
c'est vrai mais en dehors de pierre
mauroy y avait personne
je souligne également qu'il n'ya pas eu
unanimité contre amos qui a été dit
parce que certains des membres était
absent au moment du vote
et oui c'était pas l'unanimité bon cela
dit en dehors de ce problème du comité
balladur
plus récemment nous avons eu à
l'institut d'études politiques de paris
une réunion consacrée au cumul des
mandats avec la participation notamment
de monsieur edouard balladur de monsieur
jospin de monsieur rocard et d'autres
personnalités tout à fait importante sur
le cumul des mandats ou l'unanimité n'a
pas été fait mais où certaines
propositions intéressantes ont été
mentionnés notamment celle qui
consistait à penser qu'il faudrait des
règles différentes en ce qui concerne
les sénateurs et les députés
je ne reviens pas sur sept ce colloque
du j'évite part je vous renvoie
simplement aux travaux de ce colloque
alors les arguments qui sont en faveur
de la limitation du cumul des mandats on
était bien développée par monsieur bell
tout à l'heure le problème de la
disponibilité des élus le problème de
l'ouverture de la vie politique
le problème de
attentes de l'opinion publique les
problèmes de l'exemple de l'étranger
désolé de dire que les arguments en
faveur de ces quatre éléments et ben bof
ce poste se retourner de la même façon
qu'eux ils sont favorables ils peuvent
être parfaitement défavorable la
disponibilité des élus qui a démontré
que les élus qui sont qui cumule la
fonction parlementaire et un mandat
local sont moins présents au parlement
que ceux qui n'ont aucun autre monde
la preuve n'existe pas et on pourrait
d'ailleurs ici même fait la
démonstration que certains
parlementaires qui n'ont pas devant la
locale sont en fin de compte moins
présent que certains parlementaires qui
eux ont un mandat local donc la
démonstration n'est pas convaincante sur
ce point deuxième élément l'ouverture de
la vie politique alors cela et vient
peut-être de ce que l'on a changé le
déroulement de la carrière politique par
rapport à l'époque de la troisième
république ou à la troisième sous la
troisième république avait tout un
cursus qui commençait avec conseiller
municipal puis conseiller
d'arrondissement puis conseiller général
puis député puis sénateur ça faisait
toute une vie naturellement nous avons
un peu perdu cela de vue et nous n'avons
plus cette espèce de déroulement quasi
logique de la vie politique je me
souviens du déroulement de la vie du
président coty par exemple qui a
commencé comme conseiller municipal puis
conseiller d'arrondissement puis
conseiller général et ainsi de suite
ils ont perdu un peu cet élément et je
suis pas du tout convaincu qu'il y ait
ouverture de la vie politique il peut y
avoir au contraire transfert d'un emploi
et lui à un autre et on retrouvera les
mêmes personnes mais avec des fonctions
différentes
quant à la tante de l'opinion publique
alors là
l'élément le plus contradictoire de
cette attente de l'opinion publique sait
que les sortants sont plus facilement
réélu que ceux qui se présentent pour la
première fois et d'une et que de 2 on
préfère avoir un sénateur maire ou un
député maire que d'avoir un seul un
député qui ne soit pas maire de la
commune où l'on réside ya donc là un
élément qui est la preuve que ce n'est
pas tout à fait exact j ajouterai qu'un
certain nombre de nos collègues dans le
passé qu'ils étaient des sénateurs
remarquable hyper présent à nîmes en
leurs commissions ou autre mais n'était
pas présent dans leurs collectivités
locales ont été allègrement battue alors
que d'autres sénateurs ou d'autres
députés qui eux étaient constamment dans
leur circonscription électorale et
jamais sur place à paris eux ont été
élus sans problème et bien non mais ça
c'est le comportement de nos concitoyens
qui préfèrent en réalité celui qu'il
voie à d'autres enfin j'ajouterai on ne
sort toujours l'exemple de l'étranger
qui est un faux exemple pour avoir
étudié au nom du sénat 13 parlement
européen parmi les plus représentés sur
ces 13 parlement européen deux seulement
1 tient dix le cumul des mandats deux
qui sont le parlement grec mais cela a
été de pair avec la multiplication par
cinq de l'indemnité parlementaire des
députés grecs et d'autre part c'est le
cas des parlementaires polonais ou les
sénateurs polonais se plaignent
amèrement d'avoir à représenter les
collectivités territoriales alors qu'ils
n'ont aucun contact avec les
collectivités territoriales
donc ce sont des des mauvais exemple en
fin de compte que de nous dire que
l'étranger c'est différent de la france
est faux car il est vrai que dans un
certain nombre de pays étrangers
il y a l'interdiction du cumul de
fonctions exécutives
mais il n'ya pas interdiction de cumul
de mandat local
c'est le cas de la plupart de nos
voisins c'est le cas y compris au
royaume-uni où il peut y avoir qu bull
devant d'un local
c'est le cas de l'allemagne c'est le cas
de deux états scandinaves
c'est le cas de l'italie c'est le cas de
l'espagne
conséquent qu'on arrête de dire qu'il y
a une spécificité française
il ya des pratiques différentes mais il
n'ya pas de spécificité française dans
le domaine du cumul des mandats
j'ajoute une chose certains exemples
sont contraintes contre-productif c'est
le cas notamment de l'exemple américain
c'est que les gouverneurs américains ne
peuvent pas être sénateur ou être des
membres de la chambre des représentants
mais par contre la première chose que va
faire un gouverneur c'est faire en sorte
qu'ils puissent devenir sénateur c'est à
dire qu'ils doivent tout faire pour que
le sénateur sortant soit battu et que
lui soit élu à la place alors nous avons
un système qui risque d'aboutir à ce que
nous ayons un parlementaire scotché au
parlement ce que nous avons été ces
temps derniers d'ailleurs il faut bien
le dire
des parlementaires scotch et qu'ils ne
peuvent plus rien faire d'autre que
d'être soudés à leur siège parlementaire
et que par contre pendant ce temps là au
niveau local eh bien on puisse tout
faire pour faire qu'on sorte au moment
du renouvellement il ne soit pas réélu
alors il ya donc au contraire une
contre-indication dans certains cas et
puis il ya une tradition française il
tradition française importante qu'on ne
peut pas modifier brutalement alors ce
que je voudrais dire je voudrais dire
c'est que certes on l'a mentionné nous
sommes sept cent trente neuf
parlementaires députés et sénateurs sur
un peuple un peu plus de 900 c'était
lire en gros cette parlementaire sur
neuf sont élus locaux dans l'immense
majorité d'entre nous à l'exemple du
sénat que la cité notre cave oleg belle
tout à l'heure eh bien nous avons cinq
présidents de conseils régionaux 30
présidents de conseils généraux 50
président de pci et 114 mer par rapport
aux sommes l'assemblée nationale
six présidents de conseils régionaux 19
présidents de conseils généraux 117
président de pci et 259 mer vous voyez
que cela cela fait rien pour les
fonctions exécutives les plus élevés 500
d'entre nous qui sommes en fin de
comptes titulaire d'un mandat exécutif
local sont comptés
sans compter les adjoints au maire ou
les vice-présidents de pc donc en
réalité la règle c'est le cumul et non
pas l'un vers ce pour l'instant alors
bien sûr faut peut-être lutter contre
mais la proposition de notre collègue
bell et du groupe socialiste me pose un
certain nombre de problèmes que je vais
tenter de résoudre avec la solution que
je vous proposerai tout à l'heure tout
d'abord la même loi a été déposée à
l'assemblée nationale est rejetée par
l'assemblée nationale la semaine
dernière cela veut dire que si nous
adoptions la même loi dans les mêmes
conditions
la loi que nous adopterions aujourd'hui
et condamné un enterrement qui n'est
même pas première classe puisque
l'assemblée nationale n'examinera pas le
texte puisqu'elle l'a refusée donc ce
serait un coup d'épée dans l'eau même
aussi important soit-il que de lire le
sénat a voté un texte cumul des mondes
deuxième remarque deuxième remarque la
proposition de loi organique et comporte
des ambiguïtés tout à fait réelle
première ambiguïté c'est celle sur la
définition de la fonction exécutif
qu'est ce que c'est qu'une fonction
exécutif est ce que c'est le fait d'être
mère président causé général présidente
conseil régional au président de pci
mais qu en est-il par exemple des
membres des commissions permanentes
est ce qu'ils font partie de la fonction
exécutive qu'en est il des vice
présidents qui n'ont pas de délégation
je suis vice-président d'un opci je n'ai
aucune délégation est ce que je ferai
partie de la fonction exécutive
certainement pas ensuite est-ce qu'un
adjoint au maire qui n'a pas de
délégation entre dans la fonction
exécutive voilà une question qui n'est
pas réglée et qui mériteraient de l'être
par la suite
deuxième élément le problème
des écoles incompatibilité ne peut pas
être traités de façon aussi sectorielle
surtout à la veille d'une transformation
assez profonde des collectivités
territoriales où nous allons avoir un
conseiller territorial qui méritera un
examen particulier en ce qui concerne
les incompatibilités
de même on ne peut pas brutalement viser
les établissements publics
intercommunaux comme les les communes
les communautés de communes ou
communautés d'un d'agglomération sans
regarder de près le fonctionnement de
ceux ci et ça se rendre compte que les
conséquences d'une telle loi risque
d'être extrêmement importante quand par
exemple le maire d'une communauté de
l'agglomération est le maire de la
grande ville il ya une logique si on
interdit à l'avenir ce genre de choses
bien la logique disparaît et je donne
pas lourd du bon fonctionnement des
communautés d'agglomération et des
communautés de communes dans un certain
nombre de cas j'ajoute et cela a été
souligné par l'une des personnalités que
les avons 10 youn et que certaines
communautés de communes ne fonctionne
que parce qu'un parlementaire est à leur
tête
autre avancée communauté de communes
n'arriverait pas fonctionné aurait une
existence complètement anecdotique
alors voilà un problème qui est posée de
même l'interdiction du cumul de toute
fonction exécutive
est-ce que cela joue pour les toutes
petites communes
est-ce que l'on ne l'on va dire que
parce qu'on est maire d'une commune de
200 habitants
on ne pourra pas de parlementaires et
enfin comment est ce que l'on pourra
justifier du lien entre un sénateur
représentant les collectivités
territoriales à partir du moment où on
va interdire tout bien avec ces
collectivités territoriales et sénateurs
ensuite un certain nombre de préalables
ne sont pas réglés première préalable
nous n'avons toujours pas d'étude
d'impact sur le cumul des mandats
j'aimerais bien qu'on l'ait que l'on
voit les conséquences réelles que cela
aurait sur le terrain de même deuxième
élément il faudra effectivement que dans
l'hypothèse où cette loi un jour passera
que l'on est
une analyse précise du statut du
président de conseil général du
président de conseil régional du
président de la grande pci ou du
président du maire d'une grande ville
pour l'instant le statut est insuffisant
je rêve d'un statut comparable à celui
du parlementaire qui éviterait justement
un certain nombre de de cumul de
fonctions parce que dans l'état actuel
des choses
certains parlementaires ne peuvent pas
mener à bien leur tâche s'ils n'ont pas
un mandat local avec alors il ya aussi
d'autres éléments qui interviennent
premiers éléments nous avons une loi
organique qui a été déposée au mois
d'octobre dernier la loi numéro 62 sur
le notamment le problème du cumul pour
les établissements publics de
coopération intercommunale dont on peut
pas court circuiter comme cela un projet
de loi organique qui est déposée qui par
conséquent fera l'objet d'un examen dans
un avenir proche
ensuite deuxième élément je rappelle que
nous allons être saisis au cours de
l'année à venir de la codification de la
recodification du code électoral c'est à
dire que nous allons avoir à examiner la
loi organique qui gèrent nos
incompatibilité notamment et d'autre
part la loi ordinaire qui va refondre le
code électoral qui est devenue une
monstruosité et il convient
naturellement de revoir dans son
ensemble alors là encore nous aurons un
nouveau rendez vous alors plutôt que de
faire un vote qui n'auraient pas de
portée réelle
je vais vous proposer la solution
suivant la seule chose suivante c'est de
faire en sorte de faire en sorte que la
proposition de loi bénéficie gain d'un
statut qui démontre qu'on ne veut pas
l'enterrer que l'on veut travailler
cette question mais dans un contexte
plus vaste et nous avons des précédents
qui démontre que cela marche
l'exemple de la loi de madame briques
qui a été revu hier et qui a fait
l'objet d'une refonte avec la loi venant
de la salle du proposition de loi venant
de l'assemblée nationale démontre que
lorsque l'on renvoie un texte en
commission
on ne l'entend pas au contraire cela
permet de lui donner
villenouvelle je préfère donc cette
solution à celle qui consisterait à
adopter une position qui ne saurait qui
seraient immédiatement contredite ans le
vote de la semaine dernière de
l'assemblée nationale donc je vous
proposerai pour l'efficacité de la suite
des opérations que le texte proposé par
le groupe socialiste soit renvoyée en
commission
merci une seule valeur la parole est
ainsi michel mercier ministre de
l'espace rural et de l'aménagement du
territoire monsieur le président
monsieur le président monsieur le
président la commission des lois mais
sera porteur mesdames et messieurs et
des sénateurs la proposition de loi
présentée par monsieur belle que nous
sommes en train d'étudier ce matin est
une proposition extrêmement
intéressantes comme l'a dit monsieur
bell lui même et et traite d'un problème
et je souligne je sue dit juste non tu
as tout dit que la position de monsieur
belle parce que c'est pas celle de tous
les membres de son groupe et cela
présente donc un vrai intérêt parce que
comme toujours avant de venir j'ai lu
avec intérêt est les travaux de la
commission des lois du sénat
il est toujours extrêmement intéressant
et passionnant
avant de venir aux discussions de
regarder comment la discussion a été
préparé et le rapport se génère mais
également la séance d'un travail de la
commission est sur ce point extrêmement
instructives et me permets tout à fait
de dire ce que j'ai dit avec vérité mais
ça peut arriver ça peut arriver monsieur
bell il ya aucun problème
la question du cumul est une question
lancinante souvent traités avec
hypocrisie comme l'a indiqué monsieur
bell c'est tout à fait vrai et puis au
fil du temps avec des textes impartial
qui arrivent parfois à des résultats pas
toujours bien explicable moi j'ai envie
de poser une ou deux questions
d'abord pourquoi est-ce que la situation
française est si différente de celle que
l'on peut trouver dans d'autres pays on
peut avoir beaucoup d'explications moi
j'en vois une ou deux que je voudrais
ajouter ou apporter aux délibérations
qui sont les vôtres c'est d'abord lié à
notre histoire et à une présence locale
de l'état extrêmement forte et dans
d'autres états européens
il ya une séparation beaucoup plus net
beaucoup plus grande entre ce qui est
local entre des institutions locales et
les institutions nationales dans notre
pays
la tradition est tout autre et chaque
fois d'ailleurs qu'il y a
une crainte de retrait de l'état du
local il y à des protestations
véhémentes
on veut toujours plus d'états localement
il faut que l'état soit présent il faut
qu'il reste
il est bien certain que dans ce cadre là
pour pouvoir être pleinement efficace le
cumul s'impose celui qui naît qu'élu
local a beaucoup moins de pouvoir sur
l'état local que le parlementaire et il
y as je crois dans nos gènes cette part
de culture importante
le cumul est vécue aussi il faut bien le
dire comme un mode d'efficacité de la
gestion locale et il est probable que si
nous voulons aller plus loin dans la
réduction du cumul
c'est très vrai que médiatiquement
beaucoup demandent - cumul ou la
suppression du cumul on dit l'opinion
publique est favorable à la suppression
du cumul
je note d'ailleurs que sur ce point le
doyen vedel avec la finesse d'esprit qui
était la sienne dans le rapport qu'il
avait fait il ya quelques années
proposerait et le mandat unique
c'était la proposition 56 mais il disait
être conscient que le mandat unique
constituerait une rupture un des
pratiques anciennes et qu'ils savaient
et que l'opinion publique y est
peut-être moins prête qu'elle même ne le
croit et que osaka soit si on rentre
dans cette discussion que la suppression
du cumul sel doit être que la fin d'une
longue processus d'un long processus de
décentralisation où il y aura une plus
grande distinction du local et du
national ce qui est loin d'être le cas
aujourd'hui parce que pour des tas de
raisons mais une raison toute simple me
vient à l'esprit les raisons de
financement local aujourd'hui les
collectivités locales dépenses hausse
aux modos chaque année 200 milliards
d'euros
si on enlève les doubles comme ça fait à
peu près 180 milliards d'euros et sur
ses 180 milliards d'euros l'état apporte
99 milliards d'euros et on voit bien que
dans une situation comme celle là
les élus locaux ont envie de peser le
plus possible sur la façon dont sera
organisée la répartition de ces sommes
ce matin la salle des conférences
j'ai rencontré ces dictateurs ce qui est
bien normal
plusieurs d'entre eux m'ont abordé pour
me parler de tel ou tel problème
ils les intéressait 7 et chaque fois
d'un problème local des conséquences
locales d'une décision nationale et on
comprend bien que fit le cumul est
inscrit dans nos gènes de façon aussi
profonde c'est qu'il y à un certain
nombre de raisons est que si on veut à
quelque sorte supprimer ou atténuer ce
cumul il va falloir aller à la racine
des choses ce qu ils le justifient ce
qu'il l'a expliqué même si aujourd'hui
on cherche souvent d'autres règles il
faut bien reconnaître aussi et là je
rejoins ce qu'a dit le voyageur que note
le mode de scrutin et qui plaît aux
français qui est inscrit dans nos gènes
et qui nous a presque depuis le début de
la république était notre mode de
scrutin c'est le scrutin uninominal
majoritaire
eh bien on peut tourner les choses que
l'on voudra ce mode de scrutin implique
naturellement que le candidat pour
lequel on va voter soit connue et que
cela une des meilleures façons de se
faire connaître et c'est bien entendu
d'avoir déjà pu faire quelque chose et
elle avoir un démontrer c'est c'est ce
sont là je crois un certain nombre de
points forts de notre système
républicain qui conduisent à ce cumul et
toutes les lois qui ont été votées
jusqu'à ce jour
notez que des lois limitant mais ne
supprimant pas le cumul
alors j'ai bien compris ce que
souhaitait
groupe socialiste qu elle fait interdire
les fonctions exécutives et les
fonctions parlementaires
beaucoup de questions se posent il les a
lui même posé le rapporteur en a posé
d'autres qui sont toutes aussi
intéressantes
je crois que là aussi nous avons devant
nous un certain nombre de points qui
vont faire avancer la question
il est bien certain que l'institution du
conseiller territorial apportera à la
question du cumul une réponse l'élu ben
je suis heureux de faire en sorte que
madame la présidente borvo participe en
phase débat avec un soutien habituel
mais je veux dire que bien entendu je
conseillais territoriale la veille
pourra être que conseiller territorial
parce qu'il sera occupé à temps plein
sur son mandat local et qu'il y aura
forcément un certain renouvellement de
ce point de vue là et qu'il faut tenir
compte en tout les cas de cette
innovation lorsque l'on aborde la
question mais vous aurez et vous aurez
l'occasion dans les textes que le
rapportera cité est également dans nos
textes 61 qui va devenir bientôt en
discussion devant senna d'aborder ces
questions de cumul je veux dire que pour
ma part je pense que seul un débat
national pourra permettre de trancher et
qui s est probablement à l'occasion
d'une élection présidentielle que cette
affaire devraient être débattues et
tranchées pour que l'ensemble des
citoyens puissent participer à ce débat
qui est qui touche tellement aux jeunes
profond de notre culture démocratique
alors devant ce texte
moi j'ai envie de dire simplement que le
gouvernement ne peux que vous inviter à
reprendre la position sur peyronnet a
prises en commission des lois
en dix ans faisons preuve d'ouverture
d'esprit et renvoyons le texte en
commission
je vous remercie
merci monsieur me nisand suite de
discussions générales la parole est un
jacques mézard sur un inventeur
rectification de la proposition de loi
ce qui concerne l' article 2 la présente
de loi s'applique à compter de sa
promulgation
à chaque parlementaire nouvelle montée
lui ça n'a pas été modifié cela veut
dire que tous se désole parlementaire
jusqu'à la fin de leur mandat
parlementaire qui pourra durer
éternellement et bien pourront
bénéficier du cumul des mandats alors
que j'avais dit en commission que la
seule chose possible c'était qu'il
fallait rajouter élus ou réélus
apparemment ça n'a pas été modifié
monsieur lézard
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
par ce texte le groupe socialiste
propose de rendre incompatibles le
mandat parlementaire avec l'exercice de
toute fonction exécutive au sein d'une
collectivité territoriale y compris une
petite commune de 50 ou de 100 habitants
avec application à chaque parlementaire
nouvellement élu comme cela vient d'être
rappelé je salue l'esprit de sacrifice
de nombreux éminents signataires de ceux
de cette proposition de loi et je me
demande mes chers collègues si un vote
unanime du sénat en faveur de ce texte
ne serait pas une réponse appropriée
mais eu égard aux excellentes relations
que le rds eu un entretien avec nombre
de nos collègues socialistes je crois
que le meilleur service que nous pouvons
vous rendre monsieur le président du
groupe socialiste et de ne pas voter ce
texte est unanimement de le renvoyer en
commission
pourquoi parce qu'il ne faut pas
confondre cumul des mandats et
accumulation des mandats parce que le
cumul d'un mandat exécutif local et d'un
mandat parlementaire présente dans
l'organisation actuelle de notre
république
un certain nombre d'atouts en
particulier au moment où l'on reproche
de plus en plus et de plus en plus sur
législateurs d'être trop soumis à la
technocratie parisienne et d'être trop
coupé des réalités de la vie quotidienne
de nos concitoyens et comment mieux
connaître la vie quotidienne de nos
concitoyens que par l'exercice d'un
mandat local de les côtes des soucis des
uns et des autres sur le logement
l'emploi lola voir y et j'en passe n'est
ce pas une preuve de bon sens
chez nos concitoyens d'envoyer siéger au
parlement des femmes et des hommes
auxquels ils font confiance localement
plutôt que des apparatchiks désigné par
des militants dont la représentativité
et réelle reste à démontrer d'ailleurs
l'opinion souvent ne reproche-t-elle pas
à de grands politiques leur absence
d'expérience locale j'ai encore à
l'oreille le discours du sénateur maire
de lyon président de la communauté
urbaine de lyon voici quelques mois
lorsque je soutenais un amendement
rendant impossible le mandat de le cumul
du mandat de parlementaire avec celui de
conseiller territorial déclarations
extrêmement intéressante vérité d'un
jour n'est t'elle plus celle du
lendemain et je peux prendre l'exemple
d'autres éminents parlementaire je pense
avec le je vois notre collègue
boumédiene thiery où le maire de bègles
et député avocat et je crois que on voit
là la limite de certains exercices
je crois que ce texte est excessif
il veut manifestement répondre à des
interpellations populaire parfois
populiste sur le travail des élus
lorsque le gouvernement monsieur le
ministre pour faire passer la pilule de
la réforme des collectivités
territoriales
cloué au pilori les élus trop nombreux
et trop coûteux ou récemment utilisé
indirectement la retraite des
parlementaires pour dévier le débat
n'y avait il pas une certaine similitude
je suis le seul avec mon groupe qui
considère qu'une majorité des élus de
cette nation sont intègres qu'une grande
majorité de ces élus se consacre au
service public et à l'intérêt général
cela ne veut pas dire que tout va bien
cela ne veut pas dire qu'il ne faut pas
réaliser des réformes profondes mais pas
de cette manière
et puis vraiment faut-il toujours se
caler sur les exemples étrangers nous
nous glorifions de l'exception
culturelle française
il serait pas mauvais dans certains cas
de se glorifier d'autres exceptions et
ne pas considérer toujours que c'est à
l'extérieur de nos frontières que tous
ceux tout est bien et que chez nous tout
serait mal oui mes chers collègues il
convient de mettre fin à l'accumulation
de certains mandats exécutifs ou non à
la possibilité d'être maire et président
de bci et parlementaires
j'en conviens à l'accumulation de
présidence 2 10-2 syndicat mixte de sem
bientôt de spl n'est-il pas temps
aujourd'hui aussi d'interdire le cumul
du mandat de parlementaire avec des
mandats d'administrateurs de grandes
sociétés industrielles avec l'exercice
du métier d'avocat d'affaires et j'en
passe mais n'est-il pas aussi temps de
pause et fermement et clairement le
problème de l'absentéisme parlementaire
en relevant tout d'abord qu'il n'y a pas
comme l'a rappelé le rapporteur de
corrélation évidente entre cumul de
mandats et absentéisme
nous connaissons des collègues exerçant
un mandat exécutif local et qui sont
très présents au sénat nous en
connaissons d'autres sans mandat
exécutif local est absent de nos amis
cycle je ne parle pas de ce matin parce
que ce sera un affront au groupe ump
et bien cette situation n'est pas
tolérable
l'absentéisme chronique doit être
sanctionné d'ailleurs le règlement le
permet mais pas assez l'absentéisme
systématique doit entraîner la déchéance
du mandat
si on veut être clair et puisque ce
texte se veut en harmonie avec ceux qui
seraient l'expression de la demande de
l'opinion publique
pourquoi hésiter à aborder la question
du renouvellement des mandats est il
raisonnable aujourd'hui de constater que
tel ou tel assume pour la 4e voire la
cinquième fois parfois la sixième le
même mandat exécutif et je ne parle pas
des petites communes
est ce de cette manière que l'on assure
la montée des générations nouvelles
ne faut-il pas envisager de limiter à
trois fois l'exercice consécutif du même
mandat peut être à deux voilà mes chers
collègues sur l'accumulation des
fonctions des mandats sur l'absentéisme
sur le renouvellement des mandats des
pistes de réformes profondes qui
n'attendent que la volonté du
législateur
vous comprendrez que votre texte ne
répond pas à notre ambition et nous
regrettons unanimement mais du fond du
coeur monsieur le président bayle de ne
pouvoir le voter en l'état
merci un chers collègues la parole et à
la présidente nicole borvo cohen seat
ses marques
merci monsieur le président alors
pourquoi le temps de cumul en france et
bien parce que en france le pouvoir tant
politique qu'économique est extrêmement
concentrée dans les mains d'un petit
nombre et en a vu hier le même débat en
quelque sorte avec le cumul des mandats
dans les conseils d'administration donc
pouvoir politique et pouvoir économique
sont extrêmement concentrés dans les
mains de quelques-uns
voilà alors concernant la proposition de
nos collègues
lors du débat parlementaire sur la
réforme constitutionnelle de juillet
mon groupe avait souhaité inscrire dans
la constitution le principe de la
limitation de l'interdiction du cumul de
certains mandats vous avez rejeté notre
amendement pourtant il ne contredisait
pas au contraire la proposition émise
par le comité balladur laquelle
correspond d'ailleurs à la proposition
de loi de nos collègues du groupe
socialiste mais il faut bien constater
que la réforme constitutionnelle a
tourné le dos tant à une revalorisation
de la fonction parlementaire pour
employer les termes du comité qu aux
aspirations démocratiques de nos
concitoyens qui n'étaient pas dans le
comité balladur mais en tout cas pour
notre part que nous souhaitons je
soutiendrai la présente proposition de
loi parce que elle s'inscrit dans
l'exigence de démocratisation de la vie
politique
vous nous dites monsieur le rapporteur
et monsieur lézard que cette proposition
n'a pas lieu d'être aujourd'hui lieu
d'être adoptée voulu opposer le renvoi
en commission
permettez-moi de réfuter un certain
nombre de vos arguments vous fait état
d'un lien nécessaire avec la réforme des
collectivités territoriales mais
précisément cette réforme si elle était
votée et appliquée mettra en oeuvre un
cumul des fonctions départemental et
régional jamais vu avec la création des
conseillers territoriaux
là on est dans le cumul vraiment poussé
et d'ailleurs je constate que nombre des
bus s'y opposent
vous évoquez les termes bivalent de
l'opinion publique sur la question des
cumuls de mandats et plus globalement
dans leur rapport aux élus on perçoit
chez eux à la fois de la confiance voire
de l'attachement surtout à l'égard des
élus de proximité d'ailleurs parce qu'on
constate aussi beaucoup de défiance à
l'égard de la classe politique dont ils
parlent comme des professionnels de la
politique et je toujours le haut
je suis vraiment peiné de vous dire à
plusieurs vous avoir dit de vous redire
à plusieurs reprises que de ce point de
vue les parlementaires sont quand même
les plus mal lotis puisqu'ils sont les
plus mal considérés
de nos concitoyens permettez-moi de
déplorer ici les propos du président de
la république renouvelée en eure-et-loir
jeudi dernier sur l'importance qu'il y
aurait à diminuer le nombre des élus le
président la république trouve que les
pouvoirs sont pas assez concentrés sur
quelques élus dont qu'ils veulent et
diminuer encore pour tenter de justifier
sa réforme n'a t-il pas affirmé contre
toute vérité qu'il coûte trop cher ce
faisant il des légitime l'action des
élus est nourrie précisément la défiance
de nos concitoyens vous avez évoqué
aussi monsieur le rapporteur un texte
incomplet partiel certes il est un
complétion considère comme je le fait
qu'il faut aller plus loin et revoir
dans leur globalité le mode d'élection
des parlementaires ils ne sont
d'ailleurs pas les seuls concernés et
les conditions attachées à leur mandat
le cumul des mandats concernent tous les
partis politiques sans exception là
dessus on mettre d'accord c'est un fait
il est la résultante d'un système
électoral qui le favorisent et qui
dessert le pluralisme l'absence de
proportionnelle à plusieurs élections ou
encore celle d'un statut de l'élu
un site des partis politiques à
resserrer leur candidature au tour de
candidats déjà installés si vous me
permettez l'expression
il est difficile d'y échapper le cumul
des mandats et plus largement la
résultante d'un système institutionnel
qui a pour objectif de maintenir le
pouvoir dans les mains de ceux qui l'ont
déjà il est urgent de partager ce
pouvoir avec nos concitoyens si nous ne
voulons pas faire perdurer
l'actuelle crise grave grave de la
représentation politique aujourd'hui se
creusent un fossé entre nos concitoyens
et ceux qui sont censés les représenter
il y as crise parce que les décideurs
économiques et politiques ne répondent
pas aux attentes populaires l'actualité
en témoigne avec la réforme des
retraites
comment nos concitoyennes se sentirait
pas plus ou moins ou du moins mal
représentée à fortiori dans sa
composition
le parlement n'est absolument pas
représentatif de la société telle
qu'elle est j'ai eu déjà l'occasion
d'exprimer ici combien cette déformation
systématique
tonnes des problèmes majeurs de notre
démocratie il n'ya pas d'ouvriers au
parlement il n'y a pas de représentants
de minorités visibles
il n'y a pas de jeunes le parlement est
de plus en plus vieux
la moyenne d'âge au parlement en tout
cas à l'assemblée nationale n'a fait que
croître depuis la libération
c'est bien une question de fond à
laquelle vous refuser de répondre celle
d'une véritable démocratisation des
institutions
c'est là que réside l'intérêt ou non
d'interdire le cumul des mandats comme
la question du renouvellement des
mandats
cette démocratisation implique
d'affirmer la primauté de la citoyenneté
sur l' expertise la
déprofessionnalisation et là des
notabilisation de la fonction politique
et par conséquent la participation d'un
nombre beaucoup plus grande des citoyens
à des mandats électifs
ce qui implique de prendre les mesures
qui s'imposent scrutin proportionnel
statut de l'élu citoyenneté de résidence
et concernant les mandats leurs
limitations nombre et en durée pour
permettre une rotation plus fréquentes
et donc plus démocratique de l'exercice
des responsabilités électives
vous évoquez le risque d'une
professionnalisation des fonctions d'élu
s'ils étaient prohibés les cumuls de
mandats les apparatchiks élus vous
craignez que les parlementaires ne soit
coupé des réalités de la vie locale
ce serait effectivement dommageable mais
pourquoi ne pas penser que le fait
d'avoir des mandats successifs d'avoir
un mandat local exécutif et ensuite un
mandat parlementaire et de ne pas
cumuler les deux seraient moins
instructif que de cumuler des fonctions
qui font qu'on les fait toutes moins
bien il est décisif que soit créé les
conditions d'un rapport régulier entre
les parlementaires et les électeurs
pourquoi ne pas prévoir dans la loi
l'obligation pour les parlementaires de
venir présenter les projets doit dans
leur circonscription d'en débattre avec
leurs citoyennes et citoyens pourquoi ne
pas instaurer des conseils de
circonscription et cetera et cetera
il est de la responsabilité des
législateurs que nous sommes d'inventer
des formes nouvelles d'immersion dans la
vie locale il ya en outre l'avantagé
d'associer là population aux choix qui
les concerne vous le voyez mon soutient
cette proposition de loi n'est pas une
simple question de principe
il se fonde sur une conception profonde
l'urgence d'une démocratisation de la
vie politique dans tous ses aspects
par conséquent bien évidemment nous ne
voterons pas le renvoi en commission
merci mes chers collègues par l'état
yves détraigne
c'est lui le seul président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la
proposition de loi organique
nous examinons soulève une question dans
moins qu'on puisse dire est qu'elle est
chargée dandy valence d'un côté nombre
d'élus qui peut qui prône une
réglementation plus stricte du cumul des
mandats sont souvent eux mêmes en
situation de cumul et d'un autre côté
les électeurs dont on ne cesse de nous
dire qu'ils ne veulent plus des élus
cumulards ne cesse pas non plus à chaque
rendez vous électoral de donner la
préférence aux candidats qu'ils exercent
déjà les fonctions locales et dante team
est consciemment en situation de cumul
voire même de cumul multiplier oserai-je
dire que nous avons parmi les co
signataires de la proposition de loi
organique nous examinons un collègue qui
a dit lui même en commission avoir
débuté pas en commission des lois avoir
débuté sa campagne pour les élections
sénatoriales en envoyant une lettre à
chacun des maires de son département
pour leur dire que s'il était élu
sénateur il resterait président du
conseil général
eh bien il a été élu voilà et si j'ai
bonne mémoire il me semble que la presse
c'est pas très anciens c'était au mois
de mai dernier s'est largement fait
l'écho du débat entre le responsable
d'un grand parti politique est un groupe
parlementaire de ce parti sur la
question
ce responsable voulons imposer la règle
de non cumul des mandats pour les
prochaines sénatoriales et les
parlementaires et je leur donnerai pas
tort expliquant que s'il avait été élu
sénateur dans bien des cas c'est parce
qu'ils avaient une responsabilité
exécutive locale
je ne dis pas cela à soyons clairs une
dénonce personne je ne dis pas cela pour
montrer du doigt tel ou tel de nos
collègues parce que je suis de toute
façon convaincu que si le débat avait eu
lieu dans un autre parti politique les
réactions auraient été les mêmes
mais bien pour dire que le problème est
beaucoup plus complexe que ne pourrait
le laisser penser
cette proposition de loi organique qui
se contente de deux articles d'une
phrase chaque île pour ma part je
considère que dès lors
que le rôle constitutionnel du sénat et
de représenter les collectivités
territoriales de la république
il est indispensable que les sénateurs
puissent je ne sais pas qu mai puis
s'ils sont dans cette situation
cumuler leur mandat de parlementaire
avec un mandat local vous avez peut-être
penser quand je parle de cumul avec un
mandat local que j'aie mal lu la
proposition de loi puisque elle
n'interdit pas le cumul d'un mandat de
parlementaire avec le cumul d'un mandat
local mais avec une fonction exécutive
locale mais je les biens lui mais je
suis de ceux qui pensent que l'on
connaît d'autant mieux ce qu'est la
réalité d'une collectivité territoriale
la complexité des questions qu'elle a
réglé les contraintes dans lesquels elle
agit lorsqu'on est maire et tout
particulièrement lorsqu'on est maire
d'une petite commune que lorsque l'on
est simple conseiller municipal
je crois même que le maire d'une petite
commune de quelques centaines
d'habitants connaît parfois mieux les
réalités de la gestion communale et les
attentes de sa population qu un maire
d'une grande ville ou qu'un président
d'une grande agglomération tout
simplement parce que le maire de la
petite commune
il est directement au contact de ses
concitoyens des administrations et des
entreprises avec lesquelles travaille sa
commune qui connaît personnellement les
procédures qui entoure les dossiers
parce que c'est lui et souvent lui seul
qui s'en occupe et et que alors que le
responsable d'une grande collectivité
il est souvent entouré est un cabinet et
de services qui parfois l'isolent de ces
réalités et qu'il traite en fait sur
tous les aspects politiques de son
mandat d'élu local
je pense par ailleurs que le principal
intérêt est du débat au parlement
gray je dirais la justification du
parlement c'est de permettre la
confrontation entre une expérience un
réel du terrain avec une approche
souvent très juridique légitimement très
juridique les parfois assez théorique
des questions telle qu'on la retrouve
parfois dans les projets dont nous
discutons je dis pas ça pour critiquer
oui je vais je suis trop loin de ce
prénom je dis pas ça pour critiquer
les commissaires dublin nantes qui
entoure le me je suis moi même issu de
la même école que beaucoup que beaucoup
d'entre eux mais ce considère que les
parlementaires savent d'autant mieux ce
qu'on peut mais tous ne pas mettre dans
une loi ce qu'on peut faire ou ne pas
faire sur le terrain qu'ils exercent des
responsabilités d'élus locaux
rien ne peut remplacer l'expérience du
terrain et particulièrement au sénat
cette approche ne veut pas dire que je
considère que tout va très bien qu'il
n'ya rien à changer aux règles
existantes en matière de cumul
non je pense simplement qu'on ne peut
pas limiter la question du cumul à celle
du cumul entre un mandat parlementaire
et une fonction exécutive locale
certaines responsabilités dont on ne
parle pratiquement jamais dans cette
réflexion sur le cumul sont pourtant
aussi prenante sinon plus pour un élu
que la responsabilité d'un exécutif
local surtout si c'est celui d'un
exécutif d'une petite commune je pense
notamment qu'on peut parfois se trouver
dans une situation proche du conflit
d'intérêts notre collègue les arias à
lyon par les fonctions professionnelles
ou les responsabilités non électives que
l'on peut exercer tout en étant
parlementaire et que cela pose pas
rivaux et que cela pose certainement
plus de problèmes pour la démocratie que
le cumul d'un mandat d'élu local avec
celui de parlementaire par ailleurs si
l'on veut interdire à tout responsable
d'un exécutif local qui a dû abandonner
ses activités professionnelles pour
exercer son mandat d'être en même temps
parlementaire alors il faut
effectivement se re soulevait la
question du statut de l'élu à moins que
l'on souhaite voir plus d'agents de la
fonction publique et plus de retraités
qu'aujourd'hui exercé les fonctions de
maire force est donc de constater que le
problème est beaucoup plus complexe et
beaucoup plus large que ne le laissent
penser
cette proposition de loi organique à le
groupe sorti dans sa grande majorité
votera la motion de renvoi en commission
proposée par notre rapporteur tout en
souhaitant que ce ne sont pas une motion
d'enterrement
la parole est à simon sutour
celui qui monte
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues alors
qu'actuellement la loi permet le cumul
d'un mandat parlementaire avec un seul
mandat local exécutif ou délibératif
mais également pour préciser ce qu'a
indiqué mon président de groupe
dans l'exposé de la proposition de loi
mais également un troisième mandat pour
les communes de moins de 3500 habitants
la proposition de loi que nous avons
l'honneur d'examiner aujourd'hui via
mettre un terme à cette situation qui
n'est plus soutenable
aujourd'hui elle l'est d'autant moins
que le droit en vigueur limitent le
cumul des seuls mandats électifs sans
avoir pris en compte le développement de
l'intercommunalité
si les avancées significatives en
matière de limitation du cumul des
mandats et fonctions ont toujours été le
fait des socialistes notamment par les
lois organiques du 30 avril 1985 et du 5
avril 2000
il conviendra en plus tard comme nous y
invite dans sa sagesse
les recommandations du comité balladur
de franchir sans esprit partisan
un nouveau pas sur ce sujet ce nouveau
pas nous avons le devoir de le franchir
ensemble de manière consensuelle dès
maintenant sans envoyer une fois de plus
l'examen de la question du cumul des
mandats aux calendes grecques
en dix ans ce texte est bien beau mais
il faut aller plus loin il ya il ya
d'autres fonctions il ya les offices hlm
ya les dix avaient tout ça au bout du
compte c'est pour dire on renvoi en
commission et on ne fait rien car cette
réforme est souhaitée comme nous le
rappelle l'ensemble des enquêtes
d'opinion par une majorité des citoyens
électeurs de notre pays les électeurs
qui sommes parce qu'ils n'ont pas
d'autres alternatives responsable
indirectement de ce cumul
pour en revenir à la proposition de loi
le même celle ci vient parachever les
avancées sur la limitation du cumul des
mandats et fonctions en affirmant le
principe d'une interdiction totale du
mandat parlementaire avec l'exercice
d'une fonction exécutive au sein d'une
collectivité territoriale
de ce fait le mandat parlementaire
devient quasiment unique défendre une
telle proposition de loi devant une
assemblée dans 73% de ses membres cumul
mandat parlementaire avec un mandat
politique locale qui est le plus souvent
exécutif n'est pas a priori et je le
concède un exercice forcément aisé au
populaire cependant c'est avec une
certaine fierté
oui oui avec une certaine fierté que
j'interviens aujourd'hui au nom de mon
groupe politique pour défendre cette
proposition et que les arguments que je
vais vous exposer en faveur de ce texte
loin d'être des poncifs sont au
contraire difficilement contestable tant
ils relèvent du bon sens et le bon sens
est un des fondements de notre haute
assemblée ceci dit ceci dit nul ne doit
ici se sentir stigmatisés ou jugés il
n'est pas question du passé mais il est
question de l'avenir
cette proposition d'interdiction du
cumul de mandat parlementaire avec
l'exercice d'une fonction exécutive
locale va dans le sens de l'histoire
vouloir lutter contre cette idée
progressiste est un combat
d'arrière-garde pour illustrer mon
propos je vous rappelle cela a été fait
précédemment qui a 25 ans n'était pas
rare de voir un élu sénateur président
du conseil général président du conseil
régional président d'une agglomération
et député européen
cela paraît aujourd'hui inimaginable et
il a face et il a fallu passer par la
loi pour aboutir à ce résultat en
prenant l'initiative de réforme est
lui-même le régime d'une des
incompatibilités qui est applicable à
ses membres sans attendre que la réforme
lui soit imposé par l'exécutif ou par
référendum le parlement a l'opportunité
de sortir renforcés et d'être à même de
mener d'autres réformes d'envergure
notamment celles relatives aux
incompatibilités à certaines professions
ou encore celles relatives au statut de
l'élu
j'insiste sur ces deux points parce que
sur les professions cela a été
développée mais il y a quand même
beaucoup de choses choquantes
aujourd'hui et sur le statut de l'élu
sommes tous unanimes à dire que nous
devions pouvoir avoir enfin d'un
véritable statut de l'élu
et c'est ce que nous rappelle les élus
locaux chaque fois que nous les
rencontrons au quotidien dans nos
départements respectifs car nous ne
pouvons pas effectivement faire
l'économie d'une réforme complète du
statut de l'élu et la limitation du
cumul des mandats n'est qu'une première
étape
notre organisation institutionnelle a
servi d'exemple et de base à bien des
pays soucieux de bâtir des démocraties
forte et vivante
or force est de constater que nous
sommes aujourd'hui à la remorque des
grandes démocraties que nous avons
autrefois influencé en tout cas dans ce
domaine nos institutions en maintenant
le cumul des mandats sont désormais
dépassés et elle contribue à une
certaine atonie de notre démocratie
il est de notre devoir de leur redonner
un nouveau souffle limiter le cumul des
mandats n'est la première étape
indispensable pour que cesse la
désaffection des citoyens pour la chose
publique
les français aspirent de plus en plus
être représentées par des élus qui leur
ressemblent plus d'élus femmes plus de
jeunes plus de salariés du privé de
fonctionnaires des catégories b c d
ouvriers des agriculteurs voilà le défi
aujourd'hui le pouvoir doit être partagé
les mandats électifs et les fonctions
aussi parce que le vote d'une telle loi
permettrait d'ouvrir justement
l'exercice des responsabilités un
nouveau public
cela aurait pour conséquence immédiate
de revaloriser l'ensemble des mandats
électifs
ce serait la fin des élus pressé fatigué
et surmené qe2 qui au lieu de faire
fondre souvent faire par leurs
collaborateurs ou leur administration
si bien qu in fine et le pouvoir leur
échapper au profit de la technostructure
et vous savez bien mes chers collègues
que ce que je décris est une réalité car
le défaut majeur de nos institutions et
ne jamais anticiper les conséquences
collatérales des lois et règlements qui
sont chaque jour promulgué le
développement de la décentralisation ces
30 dernières années en est
l'illustration la plus criante
en effet les transferts de compétences
accumulées en transformer l'exercice
d'une fonction exécutive locale à une
fonction demande en contre
des responsabilités de la complexité de
l'environnement juridique et des budgets
en jeu d'être exécutée à plein temps
d'autant plus que s'y est ajoutée depuis
le dock comme le développement des
structures intercommunales que le régime
actuel de limitation des cumuls n'a pas
pris en compte tous les arguments des
défenseurs du cumul sont connus et
beaucoup arc de l'importance pour les
parlementaires de garder un lien direct
avec un territoire donné
faute de quoi les parlementaires serait
soi-disant coupé des réalités du terrain
en fait et vous le savez la vérité et
peu sont ceux qu'ils admettent que me le
cumul des mandats permet voir facilite
la réélection et assure une certaine
longévité politique ainsi une certaine
sécurité financière
et comme le souligne très justement guy
carcassonne
s'il n'est pas interdit il devient
politiquement obligatoires il faut
rompre ce cercle vicieux
je peux d'ailleurs on regarde ma modeste
propre expérience rassurer certains ici
ou ailleurs le mandat unique n'est pas
un obstacle à la réélection au contraire
vouloir séparer strictement le mandat
parlementaire du tout fonction exécutive
locale et je le crois un retour à la
lettre de notre constitution
le parlementaires légifèrent et
contrôler l'action du gouvernement
il est à ce titre le garant de l'intérêt
général or trop souvent les intérêts
particuliers prennent le dessus
la tentation est grande et bien légitime
d'agir d'abord pour sa ville son
agglomération son département sa région
puis ensuite ensuite pour l'intérêt
général
les gouvernements successifs quelle que
soit leur étiquette politique s'accorde
d'ailleurs merveilleusement bien du
cumul des mandats
avoir des parlementaires à temps partiel
est en quelque sorte une situation
idéale
les parlementaires votent à flux tendu
des textes dans l'urgence contre le peu
et n'évalue pas du tout si bien que les
outils mis en place dans ce domaine par
la réforme constitutionnelle du 23
juillet 2008
revaloriser le rôle du parlement ne
sommes pas ou alors très peu mise en
oeuvre de manière effective et nous en
avons malheureusement l'illustration
aujourd'hui avec toute cette partie
de l'hémicycle singulièrement des
peuples est belle illustration
effectivement et triste triste
pour conclure je regrette que monsieur
le rapporteur et déposé un amendement de
renvoi en commission de la proposition
de loi que nous examinons aujourd'hui
car si nous sommes en partie d'accord
avec lui sur la nécessité d'associer à
la cub à la limitation du cumul des
mandats
d'autres réformes de la nature je pense
que dans la symbolique voté et approuvé
cette proposition de loi dès aujourd'hui
sur un élément déclencheur qui nous
permettrait à très court terme de
travail et de légiférer sur la
définition d'un véritable statut de
l'élu
c'est ce que je vous invite à faire mes
chers collègues je vous remercie
merci mon cher collègue la parole la
parole et un jean louis masson pour 3
minutes
je diminue devenu
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre chers collègues le cumul de
mandats et son corollaire direct
l'absentéisme parlementaire sont deux
particularité bien française
deux particularités affligeante qui
nuisent au bon fonctionnement de la
démocratie
toutefois pour un parlementaire le
problème est moins un cumul de mandats
en général que surtout le cumul de très
lourdes fonctions exécutives locales qui
sont déjà par nature des activités à
plein temps la charge de travail pour un
mandat de simple conseiller municipal ou
de simple conseiller général est très
ponctuelle elle n'a absolument rien à
voir avec l'activité de maire ou de
président de conseil général
c'est pourquoi la limitation des cumuls
doit avant tout cibler les fonctions
exécutives au sein des collectivités
territoriales les fonctions de maire de
grande ville de président de conseil
régional ou de présidente communauté
d'agglomération sont des activités à
plein temps un mandat parlementaire est
aussi une activité à plein temps et 9
nuls ne peut assumer correctement deux
activités qui sont chacune à plein temps
bien entendu ce constat s'applique aussi
aux cas des ministres d'autant que quand
on est ministre on devrait être ministre
toute la france et pas le porte parole
des intérêts particuliers de tel ville
de tel département où de telles régions
de nombreux responsables politiques se
déclare certes style au cumul abusif
toutefois dans les faits rien ne se
concrétise les déclarations de principe
relève trop souvent de l'hypocrisie
quand quant aux réelles bonnes
intentions de certains elle se heurte à
l'obstruction de ceux qui usent et
abusent du système
le premier ministre edouard balladur a
très bien résumé la situation en
indiquant dans le figaro du 7 mai 2010
il n'y a pas d' enthousiasme dans la
classe politique ni à droite ni à gauche
pour prohiber le cumul si on veut
progresser il ne faut pas il ne faut pas
se référer à la bonne volonté il faut
que la loi interviennent monsieur
balladur a raison la loi doit réaffirmer
le principe fondamental de la
disponibilité des parlementaires
pour se consacrer pleinement à leur
mission cela passe par l'interdiction de
cumuler un mandat parlementaire avec une
fonction exécutive au sein d'une
collectivité territoriale la même
logique de disponibilité à plein temps
que devrait conduire aussi à exclure le
cumul d'un mandat parlementaire avec une
activité professionnelle
par le passé j'ai d'ailleurs déjà déposé
deux propositions de loi en ce sens
l'une à l'assemblée nationale le 14 juin
l'autre au sénat le 16 octobre 2007 en
conclusion je réaffirme donc ici en
toute logique mon soutien sans réserve à
une réforme qui interdirait des cumuls
abusif de mandat merci monsieur lapin et
à marie hélène des esgaulx pour le
groupe ump
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur
mes chers collègues nous voici de
nouveau saisi ce matin d'une vraie
question pour laquelle le groupe
socialiste nous propose une mauvaise
réponse
c'est une vraie question parce que les
fonctions électives que nous exerçons
les heures et les autres sont de plus en
plus chronophages cela vaut pour le
mandat parlementaire mais aussi pour les
mandats exécutifs locaux
c'est une vraie question parce que les
fonctions électives exige de plus en
plus de professionnalisme dans ses
fonctions comme ailleurs c'est la
compétence professionnelle qui fait la
différence
si ce professionnalisme fait défaut
c'est alors l'administration qui
commande et la démocratie est altérée
c'est une vraie question enfin parce que
nos fonctions sont de plus en plus
exigeante
nos concitoyens exigent de nous de plus
en plus de proximité de disponibilité et
d'immédiateté cela étant la réponse que
le groupe socialiste nous propose n'est
pas une bonne réponse la question du
cumul des mandats ne concerne pas
seulement les parlementaires elle
concerne également les élus locaux en
tant que sénatrice aujourd'hui mais
ancien député est aussi maire d'une
commune de près de vingt mille habitants
je peux vous dire que l'intérêt général
que je défends au parlement pour
l'ensemble des français
et l'intérêt général au service de mes
concitoyens municipaux ne sont pas
antagonistes
bien au contraire cette double fonction
enrichi l'intérêt général au sens propre
je pense que si j'étais seulement
parlementaire mais le risque serait
grand de devenir simplement un
technicien du droit s'ils cumulent il y
a on oublie la dira d'ailleurs de dire
que en france on a plus de 550 mille
élus locaux et c'est indiscutablement
est sans pareil c'est considérable dans
les pays voisins on n'a pas ça et c'est
un facteur de cohésion sociale qui est
extrêmement prépondérant nous devons
bien en fait réfléchir davantage à la
complémentarité des bandas
cette proposition de loi organique elle
est donc partiel et partial partiel
parce que n aborde pas toutes les
questions que pose l'exercice du mandat
parlementaire partiel parce qu'elle se
contente de fustiger en utilisant
20 qu un vocabulaire haddock un
vocabulaire je dirais consacré en la
matière mais qui ne reflète absolument
pas correctement la réalité de la
pratique
ainsi au lieu de parler de l'exercice
des mandats électifs et d'évoquer la
question de la complémentarité éventuel
entre les mandats nationaux et locaux
on me refaire utiliser le terme de cumul
qui est bien évidemment est censé
traduire en une manière plus forte plus
véhémente ce que l'on dit être l'opinion
de leurs concitoyens il paraît que
l'opinion serait ainsi vent debout
contre ces cumulards patentés qui
dénaturerait la démocratie alors même
qu'une courte majorité seulement des
français 44% contre 42% préfèrerez que
les parlementaires n'exerce qu'une
fonction permet de reprendre ces
chiffres parce que ils figurent dans un
rapport présenté par l'un de vos
collègues députés que je connais jacques
valax et c'était sur les chiffres sur un
sondage bva orange l'express du 21 mai
par ailleurs lorsqu'un peu plus de 70%
des français disent vouloir un maire à
temps complet est ce que cela signifie
vraiment qu'il voudrait que le maire de
leur commune
non seulement ne cumule pas cette
fonction avec celle d'un mandat
parlementaire
mais c'est également toute activité
professionnelle pour se consacrer
exclusivement aux affaires la commune -
c'est en fait je crois dans ce type de
remarques la marque de leur de leur
attachement à ce poste de proximité il
faut pas essayer d'y faire davantage
référence quand certains affirment qu'en
mer parlementaire n'est en fait ni l'un
ni l'autre et qu'une telle situation
illustre la dictature de
l'administration moi je salue le respect
et qu'une telle situation illustre la
dictature de l'administration c'est ça
le respect dont il est ainsi fait preuve
à l'égard les maires adjoints des
vice-présidents des conseillers délégués
de toutes les assemblées que nous
présidons et qui me semble-t-il exerce à
leur niveau avec la conscience et la
qualité que l'on sait des fonctions
exécutives au nom de la commune de la
même manière que le ferai le maire ou le
président de l'assemblée départementale
ou régionale
la question est plus vaste et plus
complexe que ne veut nous le faire
croire à cette proposition de loi et
cette question doit probablement être
présenté sous une forme plus neutre plus
paisible plus ouverte
j'aspire pour ma part un vrai débat sur
la question de la complémentarité des
mandats et je donnerai deux exemples
justifiant que l'on présente plutôt les
choses de cette manière
premièrement les débats sur la réforme
de la fiscalité locale
je rappelle tout le travail que nous
avons effectué ici au sénat mais aussi à
l'assemblée nationale aurait-il été de
la même qualité
si dans les deux assemblées des
parlementaires aguerris à l'exercice des
responsabilités locales n'avaient
apporté leur contribution est
essentielle
or étant ullah le même débat à trouver
des solutions à des questions aussi
importantes que celles par exemple sur
le remplacement de la taxe
professionnelle
un autre exemple lors de l'examen du
projet de la réforme territoriale
aurions nous été si capable de défendre
nos points de vue respectifs quels
qu'ils soient d'ailleurs si nombre
d'entre nous n'avait pas exercé des
responsabilités au niveau de plusieurs
instances locales et en ne se fait à
même de juger de l'opportunité de la
réforme de la pertinence de son contenu
et des modifications à lui apporter ne
vous y trompez pas l'opinion publique à
d'autres préoccupations que celles de
vouloir mettre fin à ce que vous appelez
le cumul au motif que cela permettrait à
nos deux assemblées de mieux travailler
et ne montons pas à nos concitoyens en
affirmant que si les députés les
sénateurs n'exerce pas d'autre mandat
ils siègeront continuellement au sein de
leur assemblée mais disons en revanche
que moins attachés au terrain - issue
de la réalité de notre démocratie
vivante de cette république de proximité
à laquelle nous sommes tant attachés ils
seront probablement plus attachés aux
partis politiques qu'ils ne le sont
aujourd'hui
et moi je veux pas revenir un
gouvernement de la france par les
parties je préfère laisser les électeurs
choisir leurs représentants
finalement les sénateurs ont voté le
renvoi en commission de cette
proposition de loi
il leur est apparu prématuré de trancher
la question du cumul des mandats alors
que la réforme des collectivités
territoriales est toujours en cours
d'examen
ce texte pourrait avoir un impact
important sur le statut de l'élu local
avec la création du conseiller
territorial la séance en vod c'est sur
notre site publicsenat.fr prochain
rendez vous de l'actualité politique et
parlementaire les journaux de 19h et de
22h très bonne fin de journée sur public
sénat